hello guys I'm Greg and I'm John John
and I had the privilege thanks to a man
named Ryan
bonds I'm a said shoes that's a star of
the gala right and fauns at STX he
invited us is a special trailer event
where there's they showed a 3d trailer
of valerian in the city of a thousand
planets the trio that I'm sure all you
guys wanted us to do a reaction to no
cameras were allowed inside the ArcLight
we were at right we could not record it
live so we're going to talk about a
couple of things okay we have we'll talk
about the trailer for sure but we also
want to kind of share our weird
experience a little bit we thought it
was going to just be a Q&A with Luke
Mitchell and Cara Delevingne net time
Attila via telenovela
card Charlotte hop with all the other
people that is Kiera Cora
and we have to look it up on YouTube
thanks Danielle over at screen druggies
Neelu Carla she says it into 3d if it's
car so it's not going to be a Q&A we
watched its trailer
trailers badass we'll just go in
chronological order of this event they
show the trailer twice Luke bass song
comes out he's kind of funny kind of
seems like it doesn't give a [ __ ] about
press events but that's a cool director
all cool directors kind of behaved that
way but he has been kinda really Nouri
happen oh yeah some people dress up nice
I didn't at all because I thought it was
just gonna be like I'll just watch the
trailer are you sure yeah I wasn't
exactly I wasn't exactly sure what the
scope of the event was yeah Cara
Delevingne shows up and she just is like
absolutely stunning like oh yeah crap
neck down - yeah yeah this is wonderful
like she was luke race on showed up like
he was gonna go take up a sandwich
thanks Cara Delevingne manolio like it's
the premiere of hilarious yeah
horrified at disco vogue yeah and why
look like future masters yeah she's
absolutely stunning and she's purty was
funny and quirky when she came out of
her intro yeah then they showed the
trailer twice to we'll talk about the
trailer then 3d it was in 3d it was a
damn good at 3d yeah yeah that's pretty
I thought pretty smooth if any of you
guys have had the opportunity they don't
have it anymore our Universal Studios
location in LA I think they might have
an Orlando still t2 3d we don't have any
now damn Terminator 2 every deal another
coolest thing and the way the trailer
started it sounds like the terminator
song yeah we have a cuss of motifs it
repeats and then with the 3d glasses on
and watching the trailer it felt like I
was in teach you three days of 3d was
really good and appetizer it really
popped out and maybe I was surprised and
the visuals are like phenomenal like
this like I'm sure they've set us up up
a trailer in the theater with the 3d to
show you that this is going to be a
great movie going experience now if you
watch are my first trailer reaction I
did with a Evan Dollard I love the
trailer I thought it was an amazing
trailer watching this one which is not
only a better trailer but also like in
3d was like I gotta watch this in the
seeker yeah yeah yeah this looks
exciting it did look like a big you know
sprawling sort of space on the outside
moving and it looked bright and colorful
and like you know worth going out for Oh
totally and I like the extra footage we
got of Laura lein and valerian yeah
because yeah better understanding of
what their personalities are like what
their camaraderie is like a bigger scope
of the world and it's like it's like a
lot more of what we got from the first
trailer but just more a little more
expanded upon and then music in the
trailer that is so that is that Beatles
song yeah watching it in ditch in the
theatres is a rather like soothing
hypnotic experience honestly yeah yeah
we're
you're darker Trippier more foreboding
guarded yeah but it still looks really
entertaining and super fun yeah and
that's one thing I think move based on
always delivers on so I think
mughal-e-azam makes fun movies and he's
written a lot and produced a lot yeah he
knows how to make an entertaining throw
right and you know from hearing a little
bit more about this this is there's 29
comic books and this was what inspired
the fit element and at the time he
couldn't make the fifth element and now
we can sell it like infidel disregard is
one of his best mood oh he did make the
visit a good magnet letter enemy yeah
you understood and I just make it to the
internet doesn't eat your soul yeah they
will yeah you can see Fifth Element
aspects to it when you see the visual
style but then really it's in Reverse
because it was the comics and inspired a
lot of the visual aesthetic and style of
the fifth element so I'm very excited
for this because this is passion project
yeah alright this was an icon a little
weird for us walk it through it in our
experience is fun is one night it's a
little wrong it was really cool we're
it's really no effect quite yeah and and
we've never been to something exactly
like this yeah I do it again like it
looks like God dad yeah like yeah it's
just cool Ryan informed us before they
show the trailer that okay so all the
questions could be will be asked here
that's all going to be at the
after-party of Stella bar and we were
like as an after-party apparently we
missed that email there was an actual
email a check there well yeah there was
a reception but I didn't realize that it
was like this yeah where we will go I
thought it was just like ecology mixer
so we go Castella bar and they hook this
[ __ ] up man it was [ __ ] crazy Ivan
died engine about like you know what
there's a rare thing that's okay there's
not a lot of people we don't know like
we go to the theater there's only a
handful of people and then it in a giant
auditory yeah we're like theater 3 yeah
I doubt it very few people in there
they're going it would look like there
were more of us in smaller but so they
rented out the restaurant we go to we go
and there they have all this like food
there and then
everyone gets a table we were waiters
our way and then we gotta like wine and
a plan a Pathan's crazy just hooked it
up and then right like there's red gel
around it is they rented out the space
because when I got there I thought it
was like regular like I couldn't tell
where we're supposed to go then I
realized like oh really mostly only
people here and then Ryan says comes up
to us and he says like so do you want to
you want me to put you up next to go
talk with Luke in Ankara and then I
think it was like wait we're going to be
able to talk to them and John and I
freaked out naturally at opportunity
this is like so we were like did you
come back to us in a few minutes and we
had like prepared you're like we gotta
ask questions if we're gonna ask a
question we're gonna make sure to have
even everyone having helped take a shot
in a good question we thought for a
while a little too long we go in mind
medica just worked out though I think
everything was kind of it with these
kinds of thing anything that involved
like discussions are gonna remind a
little bit so we could have gone next we
did in and then about 15 20 minutes go
by
that's like have a little more wine or
two baths think you'll enjoy this which
was like we're gonna be one-on-one with
gonna be juice so nerve-wracking then we
thought for too long and then we got put
with the last er of which was it so cool
that we were we were at a table just a
table to cross in a minute eight just
like with a few other people at a table
with Cara Delevingne delivery sighs so
weird
yeah this is right across was like
making eye contact just a long time to
realize like this is like a casual press
junket thing yeah like I went on
collider today and so on from Collider
who writes articles was there and he
posted his interview that he had at that
thing first off I just want to say thank
you to all the subscribers yeah because
that was one of the holy [ __ ] because we
John I showed up and it wasn't happening
our first thing is to go we kind of
don't feel worthy to be here others like
there's something like we're not popular
or important enough in any capacity for
us to be we we immediately go to selling
ourselves short you know we've really
yeah and then we realize when we talk to
people other people who were there and
the people that invited us that like
holy crap it's because we have a
following because of like you give you
guys seriously all of you dude that
girl's the console red we're meeting
blue plates like garna living and having
like a [ __ ] ton of free food and drink
is nuts to me and I know like there's a
lot of youtubers are probably send it
seem like there are people there were
very much used to that yeah it was just
very surreal for us and as far as what
we asked them there's a couple of assets
and some questions that were nice asking
about inspirations and stuff yeah yeah
things that you could read another
interviews today I came up I came up
with the perfect question because we
didn't have much time and I managed to
get them a little lot of questions and I
snuck in now I don't it I said I have a
question I just interrupted this opera
table because no one really knew how
this worked yes I know he just lets go
can I ask you a question or is this
supposed to be like we're faking this is
a regular conversation yeah we just hang
it out or do we go round table I went
with what I do and if I feel
uncomfortable like I just roll with it
an item I have a question every man for
no reason and they were all dead you
know no one would know was in an order I
know this happened everyone ever happy
on you we were heading there and then
together I was like all right I'm gonna
ask this question because Carl looked
like a little bored throughout the night
whenever I looked over she looked like
he was bored or disinterested so like I
gotta ask a question that will get both
of them interested and I know my Luke
based on maybe you can remember what he
actually answered you understand like is
reka really meyer this is a star in
front of me I said I had I love a lot of
your movies he said what a 10-car is
like he say he loves a lot of your
movies and I just repeated that again
and then she repeated that so I repeated
it again okay no I didn't know there's
like a weird big going on the tall
restaurant the acoustics weren't great
it was kind of hard yeah I said I love a
lot of your movies you have a really
good eye for casting badass female
leading characters what was it about
Cara that really drew you
to casting her in it is a question
involves the two yeah there you go
so then look wait what do you see here
like some metaphor about tennis and
about noticing Talent well yeah I mean
he kind of he basically elaborated on
the quality that he saw in her not only
that she seemed to have a grip on her
her abilities but also that she had like
you know yeah they gave a very long and
shadows philosophical answer yeah they
seem to demonstrate this sort of innate
understanding of life and humanity and
real and fearless he gave a very long
detailed answer praising like honestly I
wish I could repeat it back to you but
the whole time he was answering for a
while
uh-huh Oh mmm listening to me the whole
time I was thinking he gave react I
can't believe what they saw I'm talking
so I think in the world I also like the
room not actually processing who I hear
zelda me I'm just like really caught up
in the fact that your dog didn't read
right now I was like all right is my
time to land a little segue into the
question Makara so I went to go ask our
a question and she's like just wait hold
on cuz she was like overly blushing at
everything we've said and she's like
hugged him I was like sweet
I hadn't seen react that way all night I
asked the right question you know what I
get after that made her blush I was like
I'm just glad I got asked the right
question you paid her intent thanks to
you and then I am usually already
competent like and it sounded gentleman
and ask for the same thing like did you
identify with the role and was there
like you seem to do martial arts in
there you have to combat training she
said yeah she had to do a lot she's done
it before to get much simpler answers
still thinking the same thing with her
like oh my god this beautiful stallers
is talking right to my eyes really
nothing the weirdest [ __ ] thing in
the world it actually said it realized
she'd be more like Valyrian yeah that's
right you did say that that's why I was
curious I was buying it to ask a
question I was curious to hop on the
back of that I felt that they only had
three of us that's like I think I asked
like a two-parter but but the one guy
would was he he took yeah I mean
questions was like what yeah one is also
like it was hard to
here in the room and and you know he had
some like preparation with his question
so I think we kind of lurched into its
actually by the time whoever was just
before you like kind of toward the end
of them answering his question or her
question somebody came up and said what
two minute work oh really so yeah like
you jumped in like right on the end of
the dog okay perfect
that's why you got take risk hey that's
our trailer removal there is another
trailer looks really funny there anyways
grab all the consoles prettier there are
a lot of really cool you know different
little look different looking places to
that in worlds you know I don't know is
exactly the nature of a thousand planets
alpha looks crazy and intricate and that
seashell place and stuff like there's
some really sweeping it's it's a rare
movie where I'm like I think I'm gonna
probably go on 3d yeah I'm like more
than confident like yeah I need nine
percent sure I'm gonna go on 3d for this
one I mean you know yeah we don't have
to tell you that it looks visually
dazzling and I think yeah yeah he'll
probably be worth checking out for this
it's actually one of a couple things
lately it is impressed me the 3d so
thank you to Ryan and STX
yeah thank you guys holy [ __ ] thank you
to you guys because we wouldn't be
having like people like Ryan at s yes
contacting us is pretty good yeah now
this is like yeah it comple here people
like going to do cool things like this
this is an art subscribe to the real
reject these reasons Jerry on Twitter
and Instagram is a social media manager
of Blum House and the real rejects and
shout out the Daniel Radford who we met
yelled Radhika's news she's a funny
funny woman that one and here's a funny
one very cool he's very cool she was
giving me the eye oh that's exciting
oh I'm sorry but Cara wasn't neither the
Luke Bryan
in the camera